and Brian this weather causing delays at
Harry Reid International Airport Madison
Kimbrough joining us now live at the
airport with the latest Madison
yeah like Ted mentioned the wind gusts
up to about 63 in this area of Harry
Reid International Airport you can take
a look behind me as you're not seeing a
bunch of people as you just missed them
walking by but there was a ground stop
till 10 pm due to equipment outages and
then there was also a ground delay that
was currently just lifted that was till
1am due to the wind which is causing
about an hour and a half delay for
travelers but again that was just lifted
we spoke to two people one sharing her
less than Stellar experience while
landing and the other waiting to pick up
his girlfriend who was supposed to
arrive hours ago
terrifying
um I death gripped my husband the entire
time and I was crying so but I survived
for good she just said it's delayed so I
figure it's the weather here or it's the
planes taxing out delayed over there so
I don't know
as for canceled flights there weren't
many but the ones we did see were from
the Utah Denver area now I want to
mention to you guys take a look at this
man right here this is Robert Robert say
hi wave yeah okay Robert we interviewed
hours ago he is still here waiting for
his girlfriend and your girlfriend's
gonna get here when around 11 40.
11 41 he says and originally it was
about 8 30.
flew back to LAX
was like got on another flight and now
she is coming back so Robert is still
here so there are still delays but again
uh the ground delay was lifted uh just
recently so that is good news here for
travelers going to send it back to you
guys